Charles Noble says you must have
long-range goals to keep you from being
frustrated by short-range failures you
know not only frustrated by those things
but you have to be able I in the only
way you delay momentary pleasure
is based on the nobility of your vision
the nobility of your goal if my goal is
to change my family tree I can give up
purchasing some stupid thing that I
can't afford on payments but if I have
no goals if and there's no nobility into
my future if I feel stuck if I think
someone else is in control and the game
is rigged
well that's becomes fatalism and what's
the point so I think you need to stop
and think and be intentional about where
you're going and also more importantly
why you're going there one of the things
that changed our lives
Sharon's in mind when we went broke
twenty something years ago my goodness I
think it's 25 years ago was the bottom
as a matter of fact now slipped up on me
the other day yeah I believe it is is 88
to 13 25 years I believe it is young
September 23rd of 1988 so 25 years ago
this week we filed bankruptcy hmm it's
an interesting thing to think about so
one of the things we that changed our
lives was that that process of going
into that mess and and and having done
stupid so big and having our lives just
fall apart around us and the the walls
falling in and then you feel like it's
an earthquake and you're how to control
and you can't you have no sense of
destiny and everyone has a say in your
life because you're a slave to everyone
in sight we out everybody on the planet
it felt like
now in the bottom of that mess with all
the rubble that is your life falling in
around you you got several choices and I
will tell you the truth the truth is I
set around wine moaned and blamed
everybody else for a while you ever
blame everybody else when you do
something stupid it's the government's
fault it's the IRS is fault it's the
bank's fault it's my mean old bosses
fault it's my spouse's fault it's got to
be somebody's fault besides me because
I'm so freakin perfect you ever do that
I did that I said I'm blamed everybody
else for a while
and so um you know I think that's the
deal and I just had to I had to go you
know what I did this I and once I did
that the thing that changed my life was
the nobility in my future I looked out
there in the future and I said you know
what this is it never again we borrow
money never again as American Express
going to call my house and ask my wife
why she would stay with a man they won't
pay his bills and yes they did do that
and I was a very mad redneck never again
I'm going to be the last Ramsay in this
branch of the family tree in debt
because not only am I going to build so
much wealth and save and invest I'm
going to teach my kids too and I'm going
to break this curse off of my family I'm
going to change my family tree once I
had that huge lie behind my goals I had
a real reason to do it then we said
about the business of correcting our
lives people say how did you bounce back
after you went broke and lost everything
I really didn't bounce I splatted and I
sat around and cried wine the mountain
blamed everybody else but once I turned
it around once I decided the thing that
was one of the key things was my faith
walk my walk with the Lord allow me to
look into the future and go I can break
this curse off of my family permanently
we will never again
because we're going to make it a family
tradition you know families have
traditions and some of them are positive
and some of them are negative and some
of them are financial and some of them
are career and some of them are about
politics and some of them are about
their education but families have
traditions what's your family tradition
do you need a new one
is your family tradition no one seems to
work much around your place maybe you
need a new family tradition is your
family tradition divorce maybe you need
a new family tradition your family
tradition substance-abuse maybe you need
a new family tradition is your family
tradition is we spend everything we make
we get paid on Friday whoo and by Monday
we're all broken blaming the man is that
your family tradition you need a new
family tradition that's the way we
looked at it and we said you know what
work we work you know our family's not
bad people I don't mean that but the
stupid things that we had done we didn't
want to be our family tradition we said
you know this going broke thing that's
borrowing money up to your eyeballs is
buying crap you can't afford with money
you don't have to impress people you
don't really life this is this is not a
way to live and we're going to change
this we're going to change our family
tree we're going to change our direction
we're going to break this curse off of
our family and so we begin to drive old
beat-up used cars and the kids grew up
in consignment sale clothes and we
funded their college funds and we funded
our IRAs and we saved and we saved and
we paid off everything finally paid off
the house took forever you people do it
so much faster because you got me to
tell you how there won't anybody talking
about this stuff then I was so weird
everybody's looking at me you don't go
you need to go get six credit cards
rebuild your credit right after your
bankruptcy that was the advice I got one
guy told me said sign up for a bunch of
financial magazines you'll get free
pre-approved credit cards because you'll
get on all their mailing lists if you
sign up for money and Kiplinger's and
all that stuff
so if you want if you want a bunch of
pre-approved credit card just sign up
for money magazine isn't that funny so
he's just stupid
so you know I we had to say
we need a new family tradition we're
going to break this cycle we're going to
teach our children how to work we're
going to teach them how to save we're
going to teach them how to give we're
going to teach them how to spend we're
going to teach our children and we're
going to leave them so much money that
they have the ability to never have to
think about money again and they'll
always be extraordinarily generous
because one of the things we will teach
them is that they don't own anything
that God owns at all and so we're going
to pass generational stewardship
responsibility called living and leaving
a legacy and now we're teaching you guys
how to do that in the new course of the
legacy journey and the new class and
then these new live events we're doing
all over the place legacy journey live
Rachel my daughter and I are going to be
out teaching you the things that we did
as we made that decision to change our
family tree we needed a new family
tradition at the Dave Ramsey house not
that my parents or Sharon's parents were
bad that's not what I'm saying but in my
house we had done stupid and we needed a
new plan and some of you sit around and
blame your parents or you blame this you
blame that it's time for you to get a
mirror you're the problem
that's the bad news good news is you're
the solution so maybe tonight you need
to turn off the television and you need
to get out some big honking scissors and
light some candles and have a plastic
surgery party and chop up all your
stupid credit cards because they've been
such a blessing so far and maybe when
you sit down and talk to your 10 year
old about going to college we talked
about never ever ever taking out a
freaking student loan so he didn't call
the Dave Ramsey show and say Dave you
know $200,000 in debt getting my degree
in theology like the caller earlier
and you don't want that to be your kid
later house in a mess
make a decision it's time to change when
the nobility of your future goals is big
enough you can live through the
momentary problems of the day